I came to New York to start my life as a
struggling writer and I was paying the
bills a hundred different ways I was
bartending I was driving a cab I was
dressing up as a moose in Times Square
there was a now canceled soap opera that
I was acting on from time to time but I
was doing all that while I was writing
my first play which was a few good men
on cocktail napkins behind the bar where
I was working you know stuff them in my
pockets come home and dump them out and
typed them up on a machine that was just
called the Macintosh at the time a few
good men opened on Broadway right and
then it went to Hollywood it did it you
know it lightning struck it you were 28
years old
mm-hmm the film rights were sold
instantly and Nicole Kidman came to see
the play she was married to Tom Cruise
at the time and at intermission called
her husband and said listen you should
really come see this play you're gonna
want to play this part and so I just got
all the bounces went my way I was very
very lucky you can't handle the truth
did you have any idea how much that line
would reverberate history
I remember oddly enough when I wrote it
it was about 2:00 a.m. and I was writing
the speech and I was getting very
excited because I was I knew I was
almost done with the play I was rounding
third base and coming for home so I was
writing with a lot of energy and I just
I you know I wrote the line in the time
it took me to type it